[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN SHANAHAN:
Thank you, Jenny.
So as she mentioned, my
name is Kevin Shanahan,
and I'm a project
manager at Peak.
Today I just wanted to talk
about our view of growth.
It's about testing
lots of ideas,
and some of the
principles and process
that you can use yourselves
to grow sustainably.
So I'm going to use
a lot of examples
from Peak in my presentation.
So just as a bit of
context as to who we are,
we're a brain-training app
on both Android and iOS.
We have more than 40
games within the app
to train your cognitive skills.
We're a free app to
download, but if you
want to access the
full set of features,
you need to upgrade to a
Pro subscription for that.
So we're what's called a
freemium app business model.
Cool.
So jumping into growth
is testing lots of ideas.
So to begin with, I just
wanted to illustrate the point
by showing you four
different conversion tests
that we've run in
the past six months.
And I was hoping to
ask the audience which
one-- similar to what Jenny
did, which one you think
had the biggest impact
on our conversion rate.
So if we take them in
turn, the first one
was making the ability
to replay games
in a given day a Pro feature.
The second one was
reducing the price of Pro
by 25% in our top two markets.
The third one was
bundling add-on modules
from our partners, such as
Cambridge and Yale University,
into the Pro subscription.
And the fourth one was showing
a preview of Pro-only content,
so that users could
actually see what they're
getting before they buy it.
So which one do you guys
think had the biggest impact?
D?
Hearing lots of
different letters.
Maybe for A, show of hands?
Cool.
For B?
For C?
Not a popular one.
For D?
Wow, OK.
So that's interesting,
because the answer was A.
[LAUGHTER]
Making game replays
a Pro feature
actually increased
our conversion rate
by more than 50%, which
is huge for the business.
And you can go further.
It actually had a bigger
impact on our conversion
rate in the last 10
tests we did, combined.
So what's the key takeaway?
Well, basically, you don't know
what's going to work and what
won't.
So the key is to test lots of
ideas as quickly as you can.
Cool.
So taking that on board, how
should you approach testing
in your company?
Well, we think that before
you test for growth,
you need a great product to
do so, with a great retention,
if you have a customer lifetime
component to your business
model.
If you don't have this,
then what's going to happen?
Well, you'll be
adding more users
into the top of the
funnel, but they'll just
be leaking out down the funnel.
So you won't be able
to grow your business,
and you're going to be looking
like the leaky app there
in the bottom right hand corner.
So testing for growth is
by nature quantitative,
so we also think that you
need a data-informed culture
to test successfully.
I picked out four
things here that I
think we do quite well at Peak,
which might be useful for you
guys.
The first thing is just starting
lots of team discussions
about ideas for tests,
or tests that you're
running at the moment.
And we use Slack for
that, because it's
a very collaborative tool.
The second thing is
sharing test results.
We use Google Docs, because,
again, it's very collaborative.
The third is
publishing dashboards
that everyone in your
company has access to.
This is particularly
useful when you
have funnels like
your onboarding funnel
or your conversion funnel.
And last but not least,
it's important to prioritize
analytics, because it's very
easy for analytics tasks
to drop by the wayside as
you're building new features.
So our top tip
for that is always
having an analytic
subtask for the main task
that you're testing.
Cool.
But the watch-out with data is
to beware of the local maxima.
So if you follow data by
itself, that's very easy.
That's very good at helping you
to optimize what you already
have.
But it's probably
not going to get you
to your global
maxima as a business.
For that, we believe you need
a long-term product strategy,
and data is just
one input into that.
You should also think of testing
as not just testing features
within the app, but also
testing other things.
So you should also be testing
your in-app messaging,
your email, your
push notifications.
There are really very
few limits as to what
you can test in your
company, and it's
a good way of making
sure that everyone
is involved in the process.
So I thought I'd give
you one example of that.
We've run a couple
of really nice tests
on the Google Play Store,
using the great tools that
are available there.
So three tests.
The first one was changing
the short description.
So it used to be one that
was a simple description
of our app, what we do.
And we changed
that to be one that
highlights an award we received
from Google last year as one
of the top Android apps.
The second one was
changing the format
of the icon from a more abstract
one to one with our name in it.
And the third one was
changing the color
of the icon from a light
blue to a light gray.
So three very small things,
which, to be honest, none of us
had high hopes for.
But cumulatively, they led to a
50% increase in the [INAUDIBLE]
install rate.
So that's a hell
of a lot more users
that we're getting in the
top of the funnel now.
And there were a
lot of learnings
that we took from this to other
parts of the business as well.
OK, so those were
a few principles.
I'm now just going
to briefly mention
how we approach process.
So similar to Jenny's diagram,
there's kind of six key steps
that we think are involved
in a testing process.
The first one is
brainstorming ideas.
So ideally, you'll
want to get ideas
from as many people in your
company as possible for that.
The second one is
prioritizing those ideas.
And to do this,
what we tend to do
is group the ideas by which part
of the funnel we're testing.
And then within that, we
will prioritize them based
on the impacts that we
think each test will have,
taking into account that you
never really know which one is
going to work and
which one won't.
Once you have an
idea of what to test,
you should then try and come
up with the minimal viable test
for that.
So that's the
quickest, easiest thing
you can do to either validate
or refute your hypothesis.
You'll then implement your test.
You'll analyze the results.
And the key one is
really to learn from it.
So you want to make sure
that the next steps are
very clear, that
everyone in your business
understands what the test
was, what the results were.
And you want to think,
is there anything else
that I'm doing at the moment
that this test affects?
So I thought I would
leave you with one thing
that we find works
very well for testing.
It's to have a shared
testing spreadsheet.
We use Google Sheets,
again, for that.
And I'm going to share it with
Jenny at the end of today.
But if you want, I can
also share it with anyone
here in the audience.
Just come up to me and
I can send you a copy.
But basically, at
a high level, there
are five parts to
this spreadsheet.
So the first part is an overview
of the tests themselves,
so description, the
rationale behind them.
The second part is information
on the segment of users
that we're testing.
The third part is information
about the control and test
split within that segment.
The fourth part are the
key KPIs for our tests.
And the fifth part are the
results and the next steps
for the test that we finished.
So the reason why this
works particularly well
is that when you
do big tests, they
tend to affect almost
everyone in the company.
So for example, people
in customer service
need to know what tests we're
running, because we might get
a lot of emails
from users asking
what's going on with the
Peak app in such-and-such?
So them having access to
this document really helps.
It's also particularly
good because you
need one source of truth
for all your tests,
one place that people can come
and find out the information.
And we find this a very easy
tool that everyone understands.
You know, spreadsheets
are not rocket science.
So this has worked great for us.
So just to summarize,
then, you can't be sure
what's going to work and
what won't, so the key
is to test lots of
different ideas.
In order to do this well,
it's important to have
a great product.
Having a data-informed
culture is also key.
At the same time, be
wary of the local maxima,
and make sure that you
test features not just
inside the app.
We think that having
a well-defined process
is very important too, and
that shared experiments doc
that I just showed you is
really one of our key ways
that we test quickly
and effectively.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]